oh yeah this was great oh [ __ ] i love
your language
if somebody says something
and it's absurd in new york we go
man [ __ ] out of here right like if
somebody's like yo i think uh john
starks is better than lebron
right man [ __ ] out of here
but there's a buddy of ours jason
who went
he goes uh do you really believe that
and that was more insulting than a [ __ ]
outta so patronizing it's like wait are
you dumb enough to actually believe this
my favorite one is uh are you all right
i'm concerned for you because what you
said was so stupid to me
and it's like you guys you have
politeness built into the culture so you
found ways to be like rude and
patronizing within politeness that's why
gervais is the the one there he is yeah
he's genius that is what he does it was
my most uh intimidating interview really
people like who's
like
i've interviewed tyson fury all these
big [ __ ] six foot nine fighters and
that was gervais
because he can make anyone look so
stupid
like if you piss him off just a little
bit
i've seen him turn in interviews before
he gets a little bit annoyed
you know i mean he starts sort of making
like little sly jokes and stuff like
that and the interview is oblivious to
it until it's too late
but luckily he liked me sharp guy oh the
the cleverest guy i think i've ever
interviewed in my life really yeah
really how about the cleverest guys
you've been interviewed by who gets that
you know what i mean who are those guys
there any podcast
quite a few few good ones over the years
wait right so so gervais like what do
you think gervais's genius zone is
well if you look
he got in front of all of those guys at
the golden globes and he humiliated them
and they are the most powerful
richest prettiest beautiful people yeah
and he didn't do no chris rock jokes
that's just like a little yeah he was
right hooking and going for the kill
like i think my favorite one is he's
like um
is something about um that was two
straight men playing gay guys so it's
the exact opposite of some famous
scientologists that we have yeah yeah
yeah and he's just like laying them out
left right and center didn't he say he
was like you're all in epstein's plane
or something like that yeah oh [ __ ] off
he goes if uh something like if the
taliban set up a streaming service you'd
call your agent
[ __ ] annihilated you know
like that's that's that's the way he is
he doesn't give a [ __ ] if you remember
that joke he got first he gave i think
jennifer anderson credit for a show on
apple plus got everybody to clap for her
and then bam yeah yeah i think what i
love about
and i'm not saying this is like a thing
that's idiosyncratic to america but i
feel like there's something built into
culture where we get to humiliate the
richest most famous people and there's a
lot of shows that do this
and i don't even realize if they realize
why that's successful like like jimmy
fallon's show like i don't care to watch
late night i think it sucks but what i
think people enjoy is seeing a pie get
thrown in the famous person's face you
know seeing like water gets splattered
in the famous person's life you don't
get to see famous people fall
and i think that's what like the
correspondence dinner we have this thing
where you get to make fun of the
president to his face and then trump
didn't do it and i was like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] man like this is part of america
the most famous people you get all the
nice [ __ ] you don't have to pay taxes
you get billions of dollars have boats
[ __ ] everybody but you're gonna stand
there in front of everybody and we're
gonna make fun of you and then the rest
of us have a day we have a day where we
get to see you look familiar yeah and
it's beautiful
and if you can't give us one day it's
hard for me to write i can't do that
with biden though cause he wouldn't he
this guy's so great you make fun of me i
don't remember 10 minutes later you
could just sit on the same joke he would
go i bet he would go i wonder how
ruthless they roll him in there yeah
he's dead doesn't he's literally dead
but doesn't it show you that like it
doesn't matter who's there
kind of liberating right
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah he'll be having
his like artwork for him in about two
years and he's the leader of the freeway
the leader of the freeway right now yeah
and in two years he's gonna be laying
there like yeah yeah look at all these
people they like fight so hard for like
a president or something like that it
doesn't matter oh no
i think we're catching on to that in
this country though like
people are just so
jaded yeah i don't know if you guys do
people still do the left versus right
thing
people don't give a [ __ ] about that in
the uk well i think people are just like
they're all like a bunch of what do you
you care about the word spazz
what was that about again now you didn't
hear this because of beyonce yeah
beyonce changed the lyric yeah because
it was offensive to spazzes or whatever
yeah it's a bit of a weird one like
because is that a bad word we don't
understand that back so so
in the uk
uh i believe it's the uk anyway but
there was this assault that the [ __ ]
society which was their creative is that
a rap group no it was based on
people
it was i think it was based on a term
like many words yeah was taken and used
as a negative yeah and spars and all
these other words were then yeah so i i
think beyonce were there somebody wrote
that lyric for her and she didn't even
[ __ ] think twice probably because in
america we don't care but but more
importantly was there a time where you
could go to a meeting and just watch as
much as spazz is in like a hotel
conference room like wow
no like i'm just saying if it was a
society that means that there was like
events no i i i think i i am
using that term is a person who has no
idea okay right just to be absolutely i
don't want to get you in trouble hey i
want to
i don't i'm not getting anyone in
trouble here they need to just do like
us just reclaim the word yeah yeah
exactly yo like
they can say
you don't think that'd be like a fun
thing you would go to that meeting you
paid top dollar
me i'll i'll be the host there we go
they'd be paying me 100 i'm not giving
them a free right just because they're
you know whatever because
what have a disability i want paid
is it is it a disability so it wasn't it
was a it was a name to my knowledge
given to
the
organization that would be it's like
kids with down syndrome it's basically
literally what [ __ ] was in america
yeah [ __ ] children in like the 80s
and they have like fundraisers and stuff
and then the word got appropriated mean
like a dumb person blah blah and so
they're trying to change the word so we
had a council for [ __ ] children yeah
yeah exactly there's like old like
knights of columbus pictures of like
catholic like cherries and stuff and
it's like oh donate money to [ __ ]
kids and it was like giant signs on like
the highway and it's like yeah this is
what the word was and then it changed
wow
yeah yeah i still i don't feel like
[ __ ] is that bad a word yet like
there's certain words where i'm like i
get like a feeling about it well yeah
i'm not looking at you for a reason now
but like there are
words where i'm like that's a little
rough that one but like [ __ ] doesn't
yeah i don't i don't feel that way about
it i feel very like whatever yeah i
think most people do when they're on
their own or when they're with their
boys most people you hear a lot of words
go flying around yeah what's your
favorite one what's my favorite word
that
is i could surmise it yes by looking at
you
let's guess what do you call do you
think i look like i would use a certain
word more than the others go on
what are you saying
you just you're just missing one swats
just shaving it off i remember when i
was
talking to um i think like an indian
girl or something like that and she was
like i can't believe you're talking to
me and i was like why and she was like
well because you look like the people
that used to bully me in school i was
like oh
okay so okay then here's a here's a
here's a scottish story right
oh my god this will be fun
this has nothing to do with sex and my
mother yeah okay
this is why you don't judge a book by
its color uh cover color
purple okay so uh i i'm in scotland it's
late night and all of a sudden these two
guys are walking down the street right
they look like you seeing these two guys
and he's starting he's all drunk he's on
him and he gets yes he goes this these
he's goddamn
he's goddamn
uh pakistanis
they come here
and they open up their swarmer shops and
i'm like it's about to be primed for
racism and then he goes
and they close them at the most
inconvenient thing
i love it
in convenience
like all he wanted in that moment was a
[ __ ] shawarma that's all he wanted
it was like thank god they came here but
like keep them open for me
so yeah so you can't judge a book by its
cover